these are cute I look like a French
Bulldog you follow on Instagram oh my
god you look like Sir Barkley Charles
Charles to Barkley
that's a compliment really that's a hot
dog you were gonna go mani the French
eat my cheese got more wrinkles in you
you're welcome
hi guys how are you
well bow you don't know us we've been
here before
y'all Grace and memories ants my name is
Margaret Cho
no relation so stop sending me your hate
mail do people not like Margaret Cho
apparently you know who she's married to
who you don't know no I know nothing
about her Maury Povich oh one of the
longest relationships in Hollywood I had
no idea how much is a good-looking man
he H well he didn't age I think he was
born 60 and I am kazar with trembles I
am mainly Thor
we're taking our spot you have to do a
one two three France
whoa that's the best we've ever done
doing slow-mo whoever we convinced at it
there thank you hey bright oh here's the
deal we just recently got back from
Wisconsin you gotta go
it's really beautiful I mean it's like
the eighth wonder of the world
when all it sucks though I'll be honest
I can't believe I use that language
you know what stinks yeah going to its
constant yeah when you're lactose
intolerant oh that's a little tough
that's a huge oversight some it's a huge
huge crippling oversight it's the only
time I feel like you take tourist
pictures and people tell you to say
cheese and it makes sense oh and it's
delightful no it was not delightful
though tell me Saint Patrick's Day
oh he just happened to be there and then
st. Patrick's Day just started happening
we didn't even know what day it was no
idea and then all the sudden there's 50
people dressed up like leprechauns
drunkenly parading down the street oh oh
and I said did I take the sleep pills
again so I told myself I'd never take
that was bad when you took that ambien
mm-hmm and you forgot you took Teddy and
me yeah and then you had that glass of a
white zinfandel that night yeah it was
insane I thought I was Maury Povich
I warned a lot of marriages that night
you
we decided that we wanted to talk about
the XA because it happens every year
you're not Irish oh I wish you'd stop
doing that
wow that was very I'm gonna put that on
a t-shirt Cloris is thinking about
opening an Etsy shop if you think that
she should I don't know how to get the
pictures on there I don't know either
last but the kid that edits easeful oh
he's so sweet he's so what's his name uh
Thomas isn't what have you done koala
Jeremy no weeks cure me was a previous
intern so asked to get paid I was like
I'm sorry
there's no dollar sign an intern in the
only dollar sign in the word that's
deserving is Kesha rakeesha free Kesha
that's a rant for another time listen up
here's one thing I don't like about it
they'll make green beer well I have to
be green I have a hard enough time
having more than two beers are not
spilling it on me yes but at least
regular beer doesn't thank so much know
who you be I wake up in the morning I
mean come on
as someone who has drank Windex once in
the life by accident and had a really
miserable time I will tell you it is
very triggering it was the ambien night
it was Sam B at night I just don't
understand why they have to get so drunk
what are you celebrating you don't even
know who say Patrick is do some either
what his name is Patrick Oh interns name
is Patrick I've been calling him Thomas
you've been calling him Jeremy oh no his
name and he is a saint
yeah I mean Tommy oh okay here's the one
thing I really don't like about it and
that makes it's gonna be offensive to
some of you the Riverdance
I look I love me some Michael Flatley I
love him I think he's a god I want them
to do something with the arms I know I'm
like just a look little one wait wait a
little wait some of this your arms are
gonna act with me have you ever seen a
river dancer pick up weights
me neither they got no much never ain't
got no who am i hanging out with because
we went to Milwaukee I feel a little you
want a little cherry Markham now you
what did I not tell you know you've had
like for those oh no what do we think
this is safe
stay well it was 14 years no how what's
the drinking games these days it's a
teenage eh no 24 24 24 24 to drink 39 to
read job are oh my god is it going oh my
god hello everybody hello I interrupt
this episode of ants rants because I'm
on vacation but I don't want to brag
alright I don't want to brag like this
oh my god okay for so long it was it was
a false fire alarm fast fire alarm and
God because these pancakes are too good
to exit the room for I'm interrupting
this episode of ants rants because of a
commercial starring me on vacation I'm
talking to you about audible.com I know
that my niece Grace has talked about
this in many videos before but I get to
mention it this time so that means
listen up for the first goddamn time in
your whole lives oh my god I have been
hanging out with clitoris too much
audible.com it's the online place where
you go to listen to books as someone
that works in a library you might think
that this might be a huge threat to my
job and yes
it is a huge huge threat to my job
regardless beautiful company excellent
website they do not have a toaster that
flies across the top but I put it in the
suggestion box so don't worry hopefully
they update soon horrible comments a
website where you can download books and
people read them for you just like how
what's-his-face edited our video for us
okay and they have over 180,000 books
you can choose from what I think I have
a couple pairs of panties that a 180
thousand years old I don't know how to
restrain myself one clue to our system
with me so anyway if you go to
audible.com slash Grace you get your
first download for free for free and
guess what you can download you can
download my niece's book Grace and style
the Otto pretending you have it whether
she got all the style from me make sure
you go to audible.com slash Grace
download Grayson style tell them that
Margaret Cho sent you so I'm a voice
very hoarse I was at a Bruce Springsteen
last night and oh my god
something got sprung that's what I say
unless you Irish don't go to the bar
it's what I say to the bar don't make my
beer green is what I say should the
green step green I think he is so
adorable eyeful why I can you get on the
GQ handsome endless you know what right
you know what we should do we should
write to Seth Green and try to get him
to date one of my niece's and then he
could be on nephew oh my god oh the dr.
green get it right Nate anything else we
hate about st. Patrick's Day Quan B then
your corne be a beef I don't want corned
beef now I don't want something that
looks like my labia have you ever seen
corned beef have you ever seen a lip so
don't sit celebrate st. Patrick's Day
and go get by Gila packs Mia's grab your
drink we'll do an answer int and we'll
cheers and we'll freeze-frame and then
you can happen on a free swing okay 1 2
3 and France and then you go with the
links so Jeremy oh do you Jeremy put the
links
I really would a memories channel i
watch we did a whole rant day about
spring break
yeah very informative I think it'll be
give you some real perspective he went
got my car detailed for me the other day
what does that mean cleaned ok a down to
the detail oh I thought he just wrote
out like specific facts about it she
said oh oh oh I got a cold I gotta clean
myself out I'm coming blank when dad
like ducks yep
hmm she bought it and it sounded like
clean class